the the folks who do manage to write for
a living uh I I think people probably
overestimate uh both the money and the
job security that goes into that because
they're they're there uh oftentimes for
the love uh they're genuine creators uh
and I've talked to several of them
who've had a harder and harder time
making a full-time living at writing
even people who have very very lofty
credits to their name shall we say yeah
like people where you're like oh if you
did that you must be made in the shade
and then they are not made in the shade
and some of them are having to
supplement their their writing job with
other work yes for sure uh you know I've
been it gets harder and harder to make
to make a living
um yeah I mean you're exactly right it's
uh it's it's not most writers are middle
class they're not super rich you people
have heard of a handful that are really
rich but most of us are not and most of
us you know there's no job security
which is okay we we go into the business
knowing that uh most people who feel you
know Chase creative fields they're like
all right they're willing to sacrifice
uh the steady paycheck for the for the
love of the living a creative life but
um no we mostly we we're always we have
one job and we're researching for the
next job it in some ways it was easier
when I first broke in this is a long
time ago my first job was on just shoot
me and so if you were on a hit show you
would work uh let's say 10 months out of
the year and most writers get paid per
episode produced so you do let's say 22
Episodes a season that's a good year and
then you take a short Hiatus and you go
back for the next season that's if
you're on a hit show but now with
streaming if you're on a hit show you
might do eight episodes in a season
yeah it's a lot less and then making it
worse is the way these Studios uh are
paying you so that in the old days you'd
be uh assigned on the show for the whole
duration of the show to help produce the
show but now they only have you for
pre-production so maybe for many shows
rather uh so maybe you're only working
let's say two or three months out of the
year so p people think of this as the
streaming strike which you just
described it as one element of
negotiations is something called a mini
room what the heck is a mini room it can
mean a lot of different things but
basically in the past a studio uh or
network they they you write a pie a
writer would sell a pilot they write
their pilot script the studio or the
network they would read the script they
say okay we like the script we'll shoot
the pilot if we like what we shoot then
maybe we'll put it on the air
everything's a long shot but that's the
other steps and you get paid along each
step but now the Studios have realized
you know they were they weren't
comfortable absorbing that much risk
maybe there's a way we could pass that
risk on to the writers themselves and so
now uh it's not uncommon for a writer to
sell a pilot script to to a network and
the network says okay we like it but
we're not sure if we want to go forward
with this so instead We'll order two or
three more scripts from you we'll give
you a small budget to hire a writing
staff but but only two or three writers
and we're not going to let you they're
not going to get paid full we're only
going to pay them a fraction of their
rate because we don't know if we're
actually going to put this on the air so
therefore you should get a discount but
that's kind of like walking in
it requires a writer to the same amount
of work to write an episode of
Television whether you put it on the air
or not it's the same amount of work and
so it's kind of like walking into a deli
and saying how much for that turkey
sandwich oh it's ten dollars okay well
how much for that turkey sandwich if I
don't eat it
it's still ten dollars I don't care what
you're gonna do with it but you're going
to throw it out Michael yeah well that's
uh that's your decision to throw
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you